la nostra vita io sono di tale e non si
siamo tim contro il team ha parlato e
quale sarà la prossima alla prossima
dante si legge poi se questo video e se
non di 37 mila mi piace deciderete voi
da prossimo slide colori challenge
scrivete nei commenti quale volete che
siano prossimo slide i colori giallo
oggi vi faremo appunto fluo contro per
la come ora vedere questa volta abbiamo
solo colori invece di decorazione sarà
una sorta di tricolori di colla live
challenge non vedo l'ora di vedere che
colori diventeranno ho comprato questi
nuovi colorati superflui super fermati
come il destro era orribile fare perché
io due verdetti 12 quindi vediamo se
arriverà la maledizione del verde la
maledizione del marrone trovandola state
un bel mi piace mettetevi comodi patati
e pop carmen piano sanità poiché il
primo turno se sentite nei rumori tipo
fenomeno unico e berlioz che gioca
ancora visto il gioco preferito che è
diventato il blocchetto che fare allora
se avete visto il mio altro video che
compra tutto quello che il mio cane
tocca sta peggio di cosa sto parlando
sotto alle gioca estivo l'economia
svizzera e alla challenge prati
silenziosi 3 2 1 o 2 faccione devi
prendere una festa allora io ho preso
uno dico limoni perché
vero e marrone rosa a circolare a me
sembrava errore
no errori lo scopo era insomma non era
come diventa mischiato con gli altri
colori o meno male che abbiamo la colla
trasparente per conto di vedere questo
gianluca è bellissimo pronti a 30 ecco
qua il mio giallo superfluo vediamo come
diventa non ho mai fatto uno slideshow e
fa perché non svizzera dimenticata di
aprirlo capito che i ragazzi scampati al
disastro in pratica la vernice era
la vernice era finita anche sulle camere
la per fortuna siamo riusciti a pulirla
comunque andiamo a mettere il camice wow
incolore stupendo questo giallo diventa
superfluo
non vedo l'ora di questa provincia
chissà come diventerò mischiate per gli
altri colori vediamo pensione il tuo
marroncino rossi co vediamo un po
e un sorta di arancione abbiamo bello
però è un po marroncino tanto sembra
arancioni o aspirazione rosa e
bellissimo però è proprio un bellissimo
colore per l'aget è proprio quello che
io quest'anno bellissimo mi sa che io ho
pescato nuovamente uncino ecologici che
non perde non bene non perderò verde non
vede altro che valete insieme al verde
la tradizionale cardaci ha preso tutti e
due ma sarebbe schermo del giorno uno
sconto e verde che cosa dire
no ho come l'impressione che questi non
c'e nessuno di murray giallo mischiato
con 20 sigarette diventi non ho detto
che torno sfigato ma anche questo è un
verdoliva scaduto
ecco qua il mio bellissimo verde o
almeno troppo vediamo di diventare mi
piace la tassa gravissimi che cosa ho
paura che diventerà tutto verde perché
il verde prevale sempre infatti come
potete vedere sta trasformando tutto e
bene il verde sempre giorno per il suo
sly il match bellissimo almeno al verde
blu quindi sicuramente è però la
validità del barca e della produzione
[Risate]
chissà se cambierà ancora ori con gli
altri io adesso rosa pianello bello
peccato che una rovinerà e quasi lampone
dai meticcio verde o rimasti contenuti
ma per la marrone marrone marrone arrone
marrone vediamo anche tocco di classe
che darà questo slam
pertanto argentata un uomo è diventato
argento verdastro ascolteremo resto
capire che con ma che può veramente è un
suicidio resto capire scrivete voi nei
commenti che cos'è questo secondo voi è
un ring on it è un po cupo perde un po
golf marra neanche un pò giallo si
capisce come esca fuori il colore dei
cento nel prossimo turno si è salvato
vorrei così brutto anche i fronti 3 una
via non mi viene pescato nei miei ho
ripescato e verde ma prima voglio vedere
almeno ripescate bene bene bene va bene
art dario nel verde ma che bello che il
tuo euro che cosa fraser
verrano le realtà è e non c'è scritto
aspettavo una sorta di bronzo bernato
che sia recuperare diventa tutto breve
allora questa punta al meglio il bronzo
che questa cosa qui corre il milan
sembra una minestra è bellissimo è più
fortunato ma riuscirà a sconfiggere il
verde la regione martini oscuro perché
le diete leonardo basta con questo brano
andiamo a vedere come di vento ecco qua
il mio arancione fluo bellissima che
bello
sembravi evidenziatore troppo bello
speriamo bene dai arancione di
utilizzare verde vediamo intanto
percorrendo perché sta diventando ha
ragione ovvero che ben calata del
magazzino e arancino ragionino non si
rivela più cosa sempre guardia medica un
bellissimo zanox è un bellissimo giallo
caramello ad averlo scaduti per prestare
da media mostarda che verte è brutto non
vediamo retto come l'anno scorso hai
tanto da criticare quando diventerà un
marrone bravissimo senza contare che
avesse un grilletto e adesso e o la loro
ma che vediamo un pasto vivo arrone
[Musica]
e ringrazia che sono belli parlati
questi colori sarebbe stato più brutto
giriamo non è marrone c per noi
[Musica]
chiaro bronzo pronto è marrone o bronzo
è stupendo e sicuramente per lato quindi
si salva un po prego gara è il mio
bellissimo nominale 16 colore questa
cosa di molto bello il mio 13 21 via
nostre moto fratello
penso che sera con la ehlers dalla forma
quadrata mano di un bel road dogs
vediamo marrone almeno migliori un po il
suo slide lo nel verde che le pecore e
li meritano uno capisce maratonina bene
male meglio verde continua sul tema ed e
un bellissimo bastardino e questo perché
troppo di vino è brutto e tu invece
nuovamente mettendo questa canzone rose
gold non può che peggiorare
rob morrow ecco qua la maledizione del
verde oggi si è fatta proprio sentire ha
voluto che per scatti due terzi è stato
fatto una tac albero con questo bertot
riesce a migliorarlo con l'inganno
vendono tutti i valori di venti adesso
effettivamente potreste che mori lo
slime troppi colori non è brutto allora
è ferma ad un marrone non si capisce è
comunque un pò giallino ma anche un po
fermo dinho caspita che colore stupende
campo brutto
vediamo vediamo un po come diventa
questo marrone con altro barra ne
abbiamo tre riescono migliorarlo col
marrone rose gold
siamo un bel po così vediamo se siamo
super gigante spero che esca giro è oggi
krasic a chiarirlo però insomma è
tornato comunque marrone un pochino più
chiaro ma è comunque marrone o meglio ma
non troppo
[Applauso]
321 via ho pescato un altro dei colori
lungo e speciali
se un pescato il verdetto preso colore
dei netbook
bello bellissimo corrotto karma facciamo
cambio no perché non possiamo pescare ma
tu non puoi mancare cambio un ufo
liquame chiare provano a parlarlo
d'estate rischiare pescare una cosa è
stato questo rumore c'è un cambio turno
facciamo tre anzi secondo me è l'ultimo
turno si può fare cambio scrivete nei
commenti se vedete che cambiamo le
regole e che si possono scambiare
l'ingresso all'ultimo turno però è
sempre che appaga alte 5 vitale
ecco qua il mio rosa
una sorta di sia guardato perugia è sì
adesso riesce a migliorarlo questo line
color comitiva nota che colore potrebbe
diventare quindi è bellissimo questo
colore la cia decimi campano dopo il
piccolo sta diventando dai un po più
rosa al match viaggia capitini e che ora
che colore così tanti colori che gravano
chomet seehofer è diventato può
rinunciare annunciano alla tabella
meglio di me the bastard
non vedo l'ora di vederlo stima è stata
una ragione molto nello spazio
all'azione mattone ma vediamo un po se
il prodotto ad esse recuperare anche il
suo slang maltrattate devo dire che
questo slime un colore che non si può
vedere la dovevamo mettere in rosa
ero certo io e normale che bello i soldi
che ride moto ti sei salvato all'ultimo
è diventato botto che carino lo bello
bello mi piace perché non vedo l'ora di
vederli attivi timido era guarda
mettendoli uno affianco all'altro
secondo me si può già vedere chi è il
vincitore dei g6 precari siete pronti a
vedere i nostri 3 2
ecco clan news live blu alla fine per
fortuna è uscito un colore carino non è
uscito nel verde marrone marito
arancione scopertissima veramente
bellissimo perché un arancione scuro e
soleggiata se si aspetta di vedere un
dio allora mi piace un sacco la
consistenza e morbidissima super prezzi
è anche il colore mi piace molto e ora
sentiamo un po di turi audizioni
fantastici
fantozzi come il grazioso stacco perché
morbidissimo fa un sacco di so niente mr
che mi piace anche il colore lorenzo ne
è raro infatti che vuoi che io faccia
uno slide arancione dal secco fino
missiva 16 mar azione quindi cosa farà
parte della mia connettere di slime
slime blu e arancio
vediamo ora è quella di evitare se vi
batte proprio a vedere questa slide era
fantastico perché me lo slime lingotto
rose gold un attimo che lo sistemo
[Musica]
proprio metallizzato che parlato è
stupendo e questo lo slime lingotto rose
gold cioè che bello suoni più bello bene
il resto punto veramente lo sly più
bello che abbia mai fatto creato forte
cosa sono i fantastici tiene l'elastico
oppure guardate un wow
che bello che siamo un po di tuoni
bollicine e non tanto però guardate a
chi è colore circolo le fantastiche
stupendo davvero bellissimo uno slide
più bello e l'uso di più bello che abbia
mai fatto di opere dati reali e proprio
fantastico il po king bellissimo pure
ogni tanto c'è qualche bollicina dai
dopo il footing
allora sì facciamo noi gli diamo un po
devo dire che sono tutti e due stupendi
mi piace che questo abbia delle
sfumature rosa e mi piace il mio più
ovviamente sono sentiti morbidissimi
penso che questi siano gli slam più
belli che ci sono usciti in quattro
gialli questi colori li hanno colorati
proprio bene wow sono proprio belli sarà
difficile votare chi vinse vero ecco la
mia muthanna arancione slime lingotto
rosso
votate il quale il sondaggio bik e jos e
vince evitato un colorato e vi
raccomando da stato un bel mi piace a
37.000 si sa se si sbloccherà la
prossima challenge che decidono poi
esatto così scrivetelo nei commenti
e ora mi lasciavo quattro case linee su
cui cliccare meno i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buone
visioni
ciao